hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing magical law
that's right just like the Muggle
Society witches and wizards are confined
to behaving within the framework of Law
and Order we saw a little bit of this in
the films like when Harry had a
disciplinary hearing before the wizard
gamut in this instance Harry performed
underage magic a Patronus charm in order
to ward off Dementors attacking him and
his cousin Dudley disciplinary hearing
of the 12th of August into offenses
committed under the decree for the
reasonable restriction of underage
sorcery and the international statute of
secrecy by Harry James Potter resident
at number four privet Drive little
whinging sorry fortunately for Harry
Dumbledore stepped in and protected him
which resulted in Harry walking away
with no charges however underage magic
is just one law in a Wizarding society
that actually has a lot more laws than
you may have thought today we're going
to be uncovering them at least all of
the ones we have information on I should
also add that I won't be conflating law
in the sense of legislation with law in
the sense of a set of principles or
scientific axioms I.E the law for
underage magic is a piece of legislation
prohibiting the use of underage magic
and gamp's law is a set of scientific
principles let's dive in international
statute of Wizarding secrecy starting
with the biggest and arguably most
important Wizarding law we have the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy this statute or Wizarding law
was implemented in 1692 in order to hide
the existence of witches and wizards
from Muggles Wizarding World formerly
Pottermore had this to say Wizarding
Society wasn't always so hidden not
systematically anyway during the
medieval period Wizards were persecuted
brutally by locals who are afraid of
magic but not very good at recognizing
it this caused many Wizards to operate
in self-imposed secrecy extremist
Wizards wanted war against Mongols but
the wider Community instead opted for
secrecy an international law enforced by
each country's Ministry of magic which
was responsible for concealing societies
controlling magical beasts beings and
spirits and making sure Wizards don't
blow everyone's cover the introduction
of law however was certainly not devoid
of controversy the international statute
of visiting secrecy has been the source
of a contentious debate in Wizarding
Society namely because people have asked
whether Wizards should be the ones
living underground this is one of the
largest and most important Wizarding
laws as it's responsible for the line
separating Mughal from magical breaches
of this Wizarding law are taken
particularly seriously perhaps more
seriously than anything else and
Punishment can be severe muggle
protection act segwaying from the last
statute which was predominantly created
to save lives on both sides we have the
Muggle protection act a law put in place
that was designed to protect Muggles
from potentially harmful magical objects
this law was partially written by Arthur
Weasley head of the misuse of Mughal
artifacts office at the ministry the
Muggle protection act was one of the
reasons that the ministry of magic would
and had the power to conduct raids
searching the homes of many pure Bloods
who hated Muggles for all kinds of dark
objects this law forced people like
Lucius Malfoy to go to Borgen and Burke
and sell off Family items decreeful
justifiable confiscation segwaying once
again from the law mentioned above we
have the decree for justifiable
confiscation which allowed the ministry
of magic to confiscate any items that
they suspected were illegal the ministry
was then allowed to keep the possessions
for investigation for a period of 31
days Rufus scrimger leveraged this law
in order to investigate the items left
to the trio by Dumbledore including the
Sword of Gryffindor registry of
prescribed charmable objects once again
in the realm of magical objects and
artifacts we have the registry of
prescribed charmable objects which
dictates what objects are and are not
able to be used in a magical way
essentially it's a list of all of the
items that Wizards and witches are
legally forbidden to modify with magic
ban on experimental breeding next up we
have the ban on experimental breeding a
Lord that I'm sure magic zoologist
newt's Commander will be aware of
because he introduced it this law
forbade the creation of new dangerous
magical creatures in Britain and was
passed in 1965. this law left the
creation of new breeds to the confines
of the department for the regulation and
control of magical creatures who
conducted these experiments under a
watchful and more importantly regulated
eye Newt regarded the implementation of
this law as his single greatest
achievement a great example of this law
being breached was when Harry and Arthur
Weasley encountered a Ministry employee
with a cardboard box containing a fire
breathing check-in I can't imagine that
this creature was not the product of
experimental breeding werewolf code of
conduct and registry the werewolf code
of conduct refers to an unsuccessful
legislative framework that asked
werewolves to register themselves with
their respective Wizarding government
and adhere to a particular set of
instructions every month a werewolf code
of conduct product was developed in 1637
which werewolves were supposed to sign
promising not to attack anyone but to
lock themselves up securely every month
unsurprisingly nobody signed the code as
nobody was prepared to walk into the
ministry and admit to being a werewolf a
problem from which the later werewolf
registry also suffered for years this
werewolf registry on which every
werewolf was supposed to enter their
name in personal details has remained
incomplete and unreliable because so
many of the newly bitten sought to
conceal their condition and escaped the
inevitable shame and Exile animagus
registry an anime ghost refers to a
witch or wizard who is able to transform
into an animal form at will this is an
exceptional ability achieved by very few
but with the knowledge of this unique
ability comes the responsibility of
registering your animagus status with
the ministry of magic this registration
includes revealing one's animal form and
one's distinguishing markings the
primary reason for registration is to
ensure the anime guy do not abuse their
abilities as the ministry is able to
keep track of them code of one to use
the code of one to use is exactly what
it sounds like a Wizarding law that
regulated the use of ones its precursor
was the wand ban of 1631. the law is
anything but Progressive and outlines
that no non-human creature is permitted
to carry or use a wand this law excluded
other magical beings like goblins and
elves from being able to carry ones
something which the Goblins vehemently
fought against this law is particularly
unjust as there is no reason for goblins
a Cornerstone of Wizarding Society to be
denied the right to use a wand
decree for the reasonable restriction of
underage sorcery this law introduced in
1875 forbade the use of underage magic
outside of school underage refers to
witches and wizards under the age of 17.
upon Whom The Wizarding Trace is still
in effect this law enforced by the
improper use of magic office was the one
that Harry went to trial for breaching
the only Silver Lining to this law was
that warnings were issued in advance of
action being taken however subsequent
offenses were met with serious
consequences such as expulsion from
Hogwarts and their ones being snapped
under Clause 7 in the event that a
student could prove there have been a
life or death situation a pardon could
be made it's also worth mentioning that
very young witches and wizards were
exempt from this rule they had almost no
control of the magic that they produced
an example of this was when Harry
inadvertently made the glass in the
reptile house disappear International
ban on dueling the information on this
document the international ban on
dueling is a little unclear from these
sources available to me it's unclear if
this document refers to the sport
variety of dueling or the highest eggs
more lethal variety of dueling it's also
unclear whether or not this document
actually has passed and if so what year
it passed likely either 1994 or 1995.
reportedly in 1994 or 1995 the British
Ministry tried to get countries across
the world to agree on this International
ban on dueling Percy Weasley was working
hard to get the transylvanians on board
rapaport's law rappaport's law was a law
introduced in 1790 by Emily Rappaport
the 15th president of makusa the magical
Congress for the United States of
America the law was put in place to
further segregate no manj Mughal
communities and Mughal ones if you
thought the international statute of
secrecy was banned rapaport's law will
shock you under this law witches and
wizards were entirely prohibited from
marrying and even befriending no matches
this is the law that prohibited Jacob
from marrying Queenie in Fantastic
Beasts only surface level interactions
pertaining to Everyday activities were
allowed under this law fortunately this
law was repealed in 1965. guidelined for
the treatment of non-wizard part humans
the guidelines for the treatment of
non-wizard part humans were set of rules
and regulations published at an unknown
date governing the treatment of magical
beings who
quite be considered human this included
creatures beings like vampires and hags
the function of this piece of
legislation was to prevent further
discrimination and prejudice against
these part humans who were often Cast
Away stigmatized by the rest of
Wizarding Society within gamut's Charter
of Rights the wizard gamut Charter of
Rights was a list of Rights pertaining
to the wizard gamut Britain's high court
of law and Parliament the Charter of
Rights referred to the rights of the
accused the interrogator and The Wizard
gamut as a whole
one such right was that the accused has
the right to present Witnesses for his
or her case this right is what helped
Harry during his trial unforgivable
curses using one of the unforgivable
curses Avada Kedavra the killing curse
crucio the torture curse or Imperia the
imperious curse would likely result in a
life sentence to Azkaban prison this law
was occasionally lifted like during the
first visiting War when auras were
permitted to use the curses to capture
dark Wizards who were still on the loose
veritasarum veritasarum is a powerful
truth serum that forced the Drinker to
answer any questions put to them
truthfully the use of this potion is
strictly controlled where the British
Ministry of magic and even if you're
able to produce it it doesn't
necessarily mean that you are able to
use it at least legally conjuration
conjuration is an advanced form of
transfiguration where witches and
wizards produced object checks from thin
air there is Wizarding legislation in
place surrounding the limitations of
this form of magic effectively outlining
what can and cannot be conjured
Apparition Apparition which is
effectively the ability to teleport was
a Wizarding skill subject to legislation
from the ministry of magic in order to
be able to operate freely one would have
to acquire an operation license in order
to obtain said license one would have to
get it from the Department of magical
Transportation crops crops are a
Wizarding breed of dog resembling a Jack
Russell Terrier the main difference
between mundane Jack Russell Terriers
and cramps is that crops have a forked
tail Wizarding law states that one must
clip the distinctive forked tail of a
Crump in order to hide it from Michael
notice residents all witches and wizards
of school age or older are tracked and
register which lists their place of
residence it's unclear if witches and
wizards are legally bound report their
current place of residence to the
ministry and that's it for this video
hopefully that should cover every listed
Wizarding law from the series I'd be
willing to bet there are also many other
laws that simply didn't make it into the
story if I missed any please leave a
comment down below also if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live